Ці кадри сутичок прихильників екс-губернатора Одещини
Михеіла Саакашвілі з українськими прикордонниками
облетіли всі світові інформагенції.
Голову неформальної групи
"Друзі європейської України" в Європарламенті Пятраса Ауштрявічюса
здивував силовий прорив,
адже напередодні Саакашвілі обіцяв йому інше.
Я зустрічався з Міхеілом Саакашвілі у Брюсселі у четвер,
і він пообіцяв не вдаватися до жодного насильства
під час свого поверння в Україну.
Але подивившись на те, що сталося
на українсько-польському кордоні, я був шокований
таким розвитком подій. Я не очікував,
що щось подібне може статися.
Попри резонанс в Україні, демонстративне
повернення Саакашвілі навряд чи ще викличе
бурхливу реакцію Заходу, вважають в Німецькому фонді Маршала.
Європейські політики і урядовці
намагаються дистанціюватися від незрозумілої їм
поведінки як українського президента,
так і екс-губернатора. "Внутрішньополітичною грою в Україні"
ситуацію навколо "прориву" Саакашвілі назвав
глава МЗС Польщі.
А експерт Європейської ради міжнародних відносин
вважає, що український президент сам собі
створив із Саакашвілі конкурента.
Відмова Саакашвілі у в’їзді була
не дуже розумним рішенням. Зараз до нього
прикуто більше уваги як до політичного гравця,
ніж він би мав, якби Порошенко
не зробив би з нього вигнанця.
Галас навколо скасування громадянства Саакашвілі
а його скандальне повернення в Україну
лише нашкодить іміджу країни,
розповів в інтервю Дойче Велле колишній посол США в Україні Стівен Пайфер.
Це виглядає як політичний цирк.
Президент Порошенко на рівному місці
створив цю ситуацію, коли позбавив Саакашвілі
українського громадянства. Саакашвілі вирішив додати
резонансу своїм театральним поверненням до України.
Є питання до мотивів обох учасників.
Адже це ніяк не допомагає іміджу України на Заході.
Всі західні експерти і політики, опитані DW,
сходяться на думці, що ситуація на кордоні
виставила Україну у невигідному світілі перед партнерами на Заході,
а подальше поглиблення конфлікту
Порошенко-Саакашвілі матиме лише негативні наслідки.